[Musique]
un week end sous le signe de la
vaccination massive à saint denis ce
centre accueille habituellement une
centaine de candidats au vaccin
ce samedi près de 800 personnes ont reçu
une injection et depuis le temps qu'on
attend le retour à la vie ancienne
alors la question est simple pour
revivre normalement est ce qu'on est
prêt à accepter mille morts par jour
alors pour ma part c'est un grand oui
parce que si je les connais pas j'en ai
même y en a que je connais que je
pourrais mettre sur la liste
en son temps la grippe espagnole quand
elle s'est terminée il ya eu en effet
bouffée d'optimisme qui s'est manifestée
ça a été des années folles années a été
aux états unis des roaring twenties zh
les années du jazz des années de
fitzgerald donc il ya eu effectivement
une bouffée d'oxygène et on s'est mis à
tout oublier pour croître sans limite
donc peut-être que ça pourrait se passer
comme ça il n'y a pas d'explosion
exponentielle de l'épidémie comme ce
qu'ils avaient prévu d'une serre donc
c'est à dire que la menace qui pesait
sur nos têtes n'existe pas c'était une
mauvaise interprétation de l'effet de se
marier anglais à partir de cette menace
n'existe plus y'a pas de raison en
dehors d'un relâchement complet de la
population qui dirait moi je m'en fiche
maintenant je veux que alors que ma que
quatre semaines à attendre ça paraît
difficile à imaginer
globalement je pense que c'est
grandement plier cette histoire de kobe
de 19
même si ça reste pénible encore pendant
quatre à six semaines la gay pride a pu
se tenir un sydney en australie
seul changement cette année la parade
avait lieu dans le stade et non pas dans
le centre de la ville trente six mille
personnes y ont assisté
précisons que sidney tout comme l'état
de nouvelle galles du sud n'a pas connu
de nouveaux cas de gros navires us
depuis 48 jours
et puis une image un sens et ce matin
c'était hier soir à paris vous savez
qu'en ce moment c'est la fashion week la
semaine de la mode
est ce que vous voyez là c'est un défilé
dans les voitures les spectateurs entre
les voitures les mannequins éclairé par
les phares des vous
sur le premier défilé en fait en driving
qu'on doit une maison français s'appelle
copernic
qu'est-ce que j'étais au lit et je n'en
suis jamais rendu compte je suis passé à
côté dans le magazine lui j'ai été élu
numéro un du fantasme des français ça
j'en suis très très fier je suis
chevalier des arts et lettres mais
numéro un des fantasmes des français
dans lui ça se sent mais deux records
bonsoir
non ce n'est pas une femme qui vous
présente cette édition du journal de fr3
bourgogne fr3 n'a pas cédé à l'euphorie
parfois teintée de démagogie qui règne
aujourd'hui dans les médias et je vais
faire ce soir quelque chose que toutes
les femmes rêvent de faire part de
givonne
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai besoin des araignées ce que je
juge les insectes sur leur physique et
elles ont de l'alluré
alors que les coccinelles vraiment je
les déteste les coccinelles pour moi
c'est vraiment des gros vicieux qui
cachent leur ignominie sous des
imperméables rouges
tu les gros pervers notre métier
vraiment un métier d'homme vous savez
pas travailler avec une femme
écoutez j'ai toujours peur en prenant au
point dans de tels risques pronostiqué
que j'aurai toujours pas qu'il arrive à
l'accident c'est une idée des femmes
le téléphone c'est une idée des femmes
de s'imaginer qu'on me traite comme des
choses c'est exactement comme si je
disais vous ne prenez souvent pour des
matchs apporter de l'argent enfin moi
même ce bon qu'à cela
c'est un faux problème et vous clara
morgane avec qui on confond on a
confondu une fois il ya très longtemps
avec lorie alors oui c'est pas le même
public
ça commence un peu à du rire ça fait
trois ans maintenant
oui tiens d'ailleurs on peut en profiter
ce soir vous de poser la question parce
que les journaux me marie toujours avec
lui avec l'ex oui et le pauvre il y en a
marre à l'euro - c'est comme ça en
france on entendu dire qu'ils sont
déchargées il ya trois ans mais je suis
fasciné par la télé réalité aussi je
suis quand même si j'adore mais je
connais tous par coeur ça me fascine les
marseillais dubai ça me fascine oui mais
qu'est ce que qu'on puisse accepter de
s'enfermer dans une espèce de cages
d'accepter d'être filmé en permanence à
18h30 lacombe et les accélérer aussi
diffusée très tôt effectivement la danse
je peux apprécier par le fait que tu
aies dense et d'une certaine manière ou
quoi parce qu'au final tu n'as pas c'est
de rentrer dedans ça c'est totalement
d'accord et encore moi parce que je
pense que je t'aurais s'est délecté du
ceg du siège est établi clairement et je
suis fasciné par ce que l'on propose à
notre notre jeunesse au fond et et moi
je me bats pour faire mieux connaître la
justice de notre pays voyez la distance
abyssal qui sépare les deux
je pense que toutes les époques pour
leurs travers et dans ma vie ma vie
professionnelle personnelle dans les
rencontres que je fais dans les
conversations que j'ai avec des amis et
des amis des modes amis aussi loin dans
le cercle des queues de connaissances
que je peux voir et entendre
je vois qu'on n'est pas un pays raciste
il avait souhaité aussi organiser
eux-mêmes donc fait le repas il avait
décidé de faire un coup de coude tout
préparé d'accord voilà les gâteaux
j'aime beaucoup le couscous avec le
geste que vous faites un essai à sortir
votre vin les gens qui viennent
d'arriver ne comprennent pas de dire qu
on soit ce rouleau est là mais sachez
qu'une raison d'état micro sieste il en
a fait un paquet ce soir pardon méfiante
basson 8 avec ennuyant puisque c'était
le sol et que c'était de la pâte voilà
il me semblait bien ça n'est pas que je
participe présent ça peut c'est ennuyeux
on dit c'est ennuyant clients belgique
québec accident et même en france moi je
l'entends souvent c'est en millions aux
communes aux éliminations si chers
téléspectateurs vous pensez que patrick
cohen a fait plus d'une micro sieste
écrivez nous et vous gagnerez du pq
votre papier toilette à gagner je vous
embrasse demain c'est l'hebdo ali baddou
saviez
ces quatre là sans même chose oui xavier
alors ont merdé
on passe de l'ennui à l'envers de c'est
normal près mais l'auto en tout cas ils
vont être mieux que de loin
hiller du chauffage à bombay la voiture
heureusement mais je pense que nous
sommes mus plus au maire n'a portière
c
90 il faut changer le nom c'est pas
possible un dupont à l'opéra et du pont
qui réussit ça n'existe pas ça n'a
jamais réussi à parler du pont de tintin
et j'ai dit non pas du tout on traîne si
je suis une star et que je m'appelle
dupont c'est fantastique c'est un
paradoxe incroyable